this video is brought to you by bright
sellers
[Music]
what's up wisecrack michael here to once
again show the ultimate value of a
decade spent studying philosophy
is the ability to over analyze tv shows
about witches and robots
this time around i want to talk about a
surprising moment in the final episode
of wandavision
the disney plus series that explores
what happens when trauma advanced
military weapons and
an unhealthy obsession with television
all coalesce in a small new jersey
town now it's not every day the scene in
a marvel tv show gets everyone googling
philosophical paradoxes
so you know the hungover adjunct who
still lives deep inside of me was kind
of jazzed about that and warning
if you haven't seen the finale come back
later i'm about to spoil
a pivotal moment anyway the scene in
question involves
two visions duking it out while asking
some pretty intense questions about
identity
all hinging on a paradox called the ship
theseus
so join me as i explore questions like
who's the real vision
are you your mind or your body and most
importantly who am i
no no seriously who am i because
sometimes i feel like it's a truman show
situation and everyone's being nice to
me
but but maybe they're actors that
they're paid and it's like do i have
friends
is my mom
[Music]
anyway let's get into this philosophy
reacts to wand division and again
spoilers ahead but before we continue
i want to tell you about an awesome deal
from this episode's sponsor bright
sellers
ever wanted to get into wine or kind of
put off by the snobbiness of it all well
bright sellers can help you
on your journey to become a connoisseur
without the judgment from a pretentious
sommelier
to order your first box you simply fill
out a quiz with questions like what's
your favorite flavor of juice or what's
your favorite type of chocolate
it'll only take two minutes bright
sellers will then recommend a box of
wine for you to have shipped right to
your home
you can make changes or ship as is once
it's there you can read more about the
wines with their special tasting cards
to tell you all about the different
notes or how to pair it if you go to
brightsellers.com
wisecrack2 like the number or click the
link in the description right now
you can get 50 percent off your first
six bottle box
so check it out today now back to the
show
today i'm looking at the final episode
of the first season in which both
visions wanda's vision and white vision
take a break from blasting the sh
out of each other to engage in a bit of
old-school philosophical speculation
i request elaboration in case you've
been avoiding the internet for weeks
there are
two visions one made by wanda with her
newly realized powers of spontaneous
creation
and the other an all-white refurbished
model that's traded its mind stone for
the cold heart of an assassin
so which one is the real vision let's
jump into the episode right as divisions
are having a debate about which of them
is in fact
the actual vision because whichever one
is the real one
is about to be brutally killed by white
vision
but i'm not the true vision only a
conditional vision
you are familiar with the thought
experiment the ship of theseus in the
field of identity metaphysics
oh wait so i honestly never thought i
would hear the phrase identity
metaphysics in an mcu property
but then again i never thought o.j
simpson would post a video to twitter
about how important it is to get a covet
vaccine
take care stay safe get your shot so hey
you never know what life is going to
throw at you
now identity metaphysics is a way of
talking about the relationship between
an object and itself or in other words
the physical object and the idea of the
object
okay that sounds confusing but there's a
difference between the physical
assortment of bones
skin and various allergies that i'm made
of
and the idea of me that is michael burns
great friend loving partner and hot
sauce enthusiast
so how do i know that the specific
assortment of bones and stuff is me
and how do i keep that identity over
time from
wee little baby michael to cranky old
man michael
okay let's watch sociopath vision
explain
naturally the ship of theseus is an
artifact
in the museum over time his planks of
wood rot
are replaced with new planks when no
original plank remains
is it still the ship of theseus speaking
of allergies i think white vision
could use some nasonex okay so the ship
of theseus paradox
helps us think about the relationship
between what a thing is
made of and what a thing is lots of
philosophers have written about this but
we can start with athens hottest
bachelor aristotle
for aristotle a thing's identity has
less to do with what it
is and more to do with what it does and
he gets at this through considering
objects in terms of
four causes what a thing is made of what
a thing should be
what makes the thing what it is and the
purpose of the thing
what he calls the final cause which is
most essential in terms of identity for
example the final cause of a knife is
cutting stuff up
in terms of the ship for aristotle its
true identity would have less to do with
the planks of wood
or the building of a boat or the person
putting it together
and more to do with its final cause i.e
being a vessel
that floats on water so me and the boys
could get hammered at noon while singing
sea shanties
god i love those guys but there is also
another part of the story
secondly if those removed planks are
restored
and reassembled free of the rot is that
the ship of theseus
so which is the original the one with
all the original materials
or the original that's slowly been
replaced this
framing of whether or not a new vessel
constructed out of the planks from the
old vessel is still the true ship of
theseus
leads us to consider things in a more
material way
and under this framework the identity of
the ship is defined in relation to the
physical planks that make up the ship
not the purpose of that thing but it's
not without problems uh let's say
the new and improved ship is no longer
the ship of theseus
does that mean that as i get replaced
adam by adam as i
age that i become a whole new person and
if that's true
am i liable for the student loans that a
different version of
of my person took out i don't think so
but rene descartes touched on this
problem in human terms
with his concept of mind body dualism to
keep it extremely brief
he argued that you are more defined by
your thinking
mind which she calls a soul and less so
by your physical body so
if i did a freaky friday with lindsay
lohan it'd be
me with gorgeous strawberry blonde locks
and a grossly unappreciated acting
career
so now we have two conflicting
frameworks
a physical definition of identity
against a more
mental based identity and one division
goes all in on this distinction asking
is wanda's vision the real vision due to
him having the spirit and
characteristics of the original vision
or
is white vision the real vision because
he is in the same physical body
as the original vision what does our
robot buddy think
neither is the true ship
both of the drew shiv oh thanks
that that that cleared it up um but
really
this is why they call it a paradox
because it seems that both
chips and neither ship is the true ship
in this case
white vision's digital brain is stuck in
the paradox as he can't decide who in
the heck the actual vision
is let's get back to it for a second
well then we are agreed
but i do not have the mind stone okay um
there's two ways to read this comment
because the mind stone lore
is very complicated in one sense white
vision is saying
he doesn't possess a crucial physical
characteristic of being vision
he's no more vision than a building
without books is a library but also
the mind stone is a thinking substance
that descartes might even say has a soul
so in one sense white vision is saying i
don't have the soul of vision
but wanda's vision has a good comeback
and i do not have one
single ounce of original material oh got
him
now juana's vision is saying that he's
not the real vision because he doesn't
possess
any of the original material vision even
though he was made
from the mind stone so if we wanted to
find the true vision
by all the physical stuff that
constitutes vision
none of us are vision so stop hurting
him but wait things are about to get
a little funky perhaps the rot
is the memories the wear and tear of the
voyages
the wood touched by theseus himself okay
so here
to escape the paradox wanda's vision
introduces a new way of thinking about
the problem one that just so happens to
be similar to john locke's take on the
whole situation
we've covered some of this in our video
on cyberpunk so check that out if you
want
vision is basically saying isn't
identity all the awful things we
experienced along our voyage
through the monstrous abyss of life well
for luck
that's basically right a little less
grim though
lock's take is even if you slowly have
every single atom in your body replaced
you still remember being you memory in
other words makes identity
and in this whole ship metaphor for
vision those experiences the memory of
them the wear and tear
that's what makes the ship unique and
white vision is about to learn
this lockheed lesson i have not retained
memories
but you do have the data it is merely
being
kept from you a weapon to be more easily
controlled but certainly you are the
true vision for you believe yourself to
be
and here white vision is reminding us
that hurt people hurt people
but um this isn't so much a
philosophical point
but white vision doesn't have access to
his memories at the moment which in lax
terms would make him definitely
not the real vision also it's important
to differentiate between
knowledge of a thing that is data about
something
from i remember personally experiencing
this thing
which is a memory that was once the case
but upon meeting you i have been
disabused of that notion
may i gotta ask for consent
[Music]
i think this is what it's like to take
dmt
i am a vision
well um that's that white vision having
had his memories restored
can now accept his identity as vision
it's
unclear whether he's going to destroy
himself or what at this point but
regardless
this all seems to more or less affirm a
lockian view of identity
accessing vision's memories leads him to
acknowledge that he is in fact
real vision rather than just of rando
inhabiting his new
and improved corpse so case
closed not so fast it would be remiss of
me
uh to not raise one final perspective on
the ship of theseus stuff it's all bull
which is not my personal stance but it
does seem weird for a couple of ai dudes
to fall into a paradox that might just
be a result of our dumb human brains
as linguist noam chomsky argues our
brains are hard
wired to perceive what he calls psychic
continuity in the world
even when it doesn't exist like if a
witch turned me into a toad
even a small child would inherently
understand that the toad
was me but according to gnome it's not
it's a
toad in a baseball cap in other words
the ship of theseus or vision paradoxes
are not about reality
but the nature of our cognitive systems
i.e
they're less about reality and more
about our feeble attempts to make
sense of reality so there's no point
trying to solve the philosophical
problem
the problem is an epistemological one
it's something about the nature of our
cognitive systems it's a bit too edgy
logic bro for my more classical
sensibilities
but still an interesting take anyway
setting chomsky's skepticism aside
overall i think the show actually did a
pretty good job of working in an ancient
philosophical paradox in a way that both
made sense and actually created some
good character conflict
so there you have it i'm either my body
my mind
my memories are absolutely nothing
don't worry i'll i'll i'll i'll be fine
i can't breathe right now because a lot
of them know
what if chonsky is right uh but what do
you guys think is
white vision on a mission of
self-annihilation or will he somehow
find redemption in his true identity
let us know what you think in the
comments and definitely let us know if
there are other shows
and movies you think are worthy of a
philosophical reaction
big thanks to our patrons for all your
support hit that subscribe button
like your street fighting your
doppelganger and don't forget to ring
that bell
and as always thanks for watching later
[Music]
that's traded its mind stone for the
heart of a cold stone
cold stone assassin that would be like
ice cream it's not that's not it i'm
going back
a cold stone assassin who goes in and
says give me the ice cream
i'll kill you